foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan and censor tonight
Ukraine says Russia blew up a major Dam
unleashing a Biblical flood which
threatens a nuclear plant the UK calls
it a war crime and as Ukraine begins a
massive counter-offensive is this the
turning point in Europe's bloody war
also tonight only fans has become a
multi-billion Dollar business now with a
record 3 million users most of them
selling soft porn photos to followers
isn't it feminist empowerment or just
downright Immortal or debate that with
one of his biggest stars
plus the legendary Wim Hof better known
as The Iceman is a wellness Guru to the
Stars says he can fix all our problems
creates a well-being anxiety and Pain
Management think of a few people today
that could have done with a bit of that
so I thought I should talk to him he
joins me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensor far away from the
breathless talk of misbehaving TV
presenters and attention-seeking reality
stars and whining members of the royal
family something remarkable is happening
in Ukraine right now Russia's little
neighbor with an army half its size was
supposed to fall under the kremlin's
rule in three days every expert told us
Ukraine will be pounded off the map and
for a while that's how it looked Russian
troops surged across the border from
three directions bombs pounded shelters
for refugees maternity hospitals
residential buildings in town after town
Russian flags were hoisted up as symbols
of a genocidal Conquest they turned
Ukraine into a living hell but a hell of
a lot has changed
ukrainians fought back against the
Russians facing tanks in tractors
repelling the Invaders with now
legendary bravery Western Arms poured in
and Putin's war machine is falling apart
we're now hearing a lot about the
Ukrainian counter-offensive and it's
worth thinking about what that actually
means it means Ukraine is no longer just
defending itself pinned against the
robes taking the blows it's now ready to
begin punching back it's fighting it's
on the front foot and it's ready to take
back his country in the way that
president zielinski has always vowed it
would
we
no minion we are not prepared to
exchange or trade the territory of the
independent state of Ukraine we have no
right for this first of all we are the
government because this land belongs to
Ukrainian people
Ukraine has every right to fight for
every inch of his territory a lot of
experts say there's no way this ends
without them giving up sways of their
country to the Russians to Putin's
barbarians but why should they how would
we respond if Russia did this here to
our country well we know what we did
when Adolf Hitler tried to do that
don't we have we forgotten do we not
learn the lessons from history when
dictators try and Rampage their way
through Europe seizing Democratic
Sovereign countries
Ukraine has to win this war has to win
it for freedom and for democracy and we
have to help them do it and it has to
win this war on its terms not Vladimir
Putin's today another reminder of why a
massive explosion destroyed a huge Dam
in southern Ukraine unleashing a
Biblical flood that will cost more lives
and even threatens a nuclear power plant
it looks a lot like another lunatic act
from a terrorist State that's getting
ever more desperate and dangerous or
fearful of the counter-offensive the
only way we stop things like this is by
bringing an end to the war
and that for us for America for the
other allies means that we support and
back zelenski and Ukraine to finish the
job well joining me now is Yuri sack is
advisor to Ukrainian defense minister
and by General Mark kimit the former
assistant Secretary of State for
political and Military Affairs and
welcome to both of you um yurisaki let
me start with you how crucial is this
phase of the war that we're now entering
with the much vaunted counter-offensive
and how damaging is this incident today
with the dam
thank you peers and I would like to
start by expressing deep gratitude to
the United Kingdom to the British people
for the support that we have been
receiving from your country since day
one of this aggression your leaders have
come to support us in person we have
received thanks we have received
ammunition we have received multi-launch
block assistance from the United Kingdom
uh the United Kingdom have been the
driving force behind the formation of
the fighter jet Coalition so we're
thankful for that now as to your
question
of course we have been preparing for the
next stages of our the occupation
campaign uh for a long time we have been
uh receiving military support from our
allies and what is happening what is
beginning to happen now the front is
beginning to move uh Russia's continue
to suffer setbacks on the battlefield in
some places which have become legendary
by now like the city of bakmud which is
entirely pulverized by the Russian
Artillery but Russians are leaving from
there as well and we are advancing
little by little uh you know faced with
this lack of military success what a
terrorist regime which is what it is the
Russian terrorist regime what they're
doing they continue the campaign of
Terror so they continue to terrorize
Ukrainian cities within massive missile
strikes just last night we had a massive
missile strike 35 cruise missiles but
fortunately thanks to the air defense
systems we have received from our
partners they've all been shot down and
at night they have blown up the dam
which create the flooding more than 80
Villages and small towns are now
underwater the water levels have risen
in some places up to 10 meters we have
no idea how many people this flood will
take away because we of course right now
cannot access these surgeries and we
will have to wait till the water comes
down the Reconstruction of the dam is
impossible it is damaged Beyond repair
we have proven evidence that the
explosives have been taken there by the
Russian terrorists by these war
criminals and this is why we are calling
now an emergency meeting of the U.N
security Council and look we are
we are aware that Russia the terrorist
state has a seat on the security Council
but still we think it is important for
us to bring this issue to the attention
of the International Community because
what are the possible outcomes has been
the threat to the nuclear power plant in
zaporizia the sac second largest nuclear
power plant in Europe luckily for now
there is no immediate threat
okay uh thank you for that that was an
extraordinary uh account of what's been
going on thank you I want to bring in
general Kim from a purely military point
of view General where are we in this war
how prepared are the ukrainians for this
counter-offensive and I guess the
overriding question can they win
well first of all uh it's it's
remarkable how strong the character and
the morale of the printing forces are uh
everybody thought this would be over in
a matter of weeks it's now been 16
months and 16 months now the great event
to come is the counter-offensive that
nobody would have ever anticipated but
one has to question uh if there is a
sufficient amount of equipment that has
been provided to the Ukrainian armies to
achieve president zielinski's War
termination goals and that's what we
need to talk about is what does win mean
if wind means that all of the Russian
forces are pushed out of both uh Ukraine
and the
land inside the Crimea that belongs to
Ukraine I don't think we provided enough
equipment up to this point but I do
believe that there is sufficient
capability for the ukrainians to conduct
a significant counter-offensive against
the Russians that would number one prove
to the Soviet prove to the Russian
forces that they have been defeated
prove to the West that this is a good
investment and we need to provide more
and more equipment and also put the
Ukrainian forces in a position that
perhaps not this counter-offensive but a
subsequent counter-offensive would get
closer to president zielinski's War
termination goals otherwise I'd be
afraid that the West would be pushing
the ukrainians to a premature set of
negotiations which would just turn this
into a frozen conflict and reward Putin
for his aggression Yuri when I was in
Ukraine interviewing the president and
the first lady I was struck by when I
spoke to Ordinary People in the street
old young male female whoever I spoke to
the absolute Unity of resolve that the
President should not cede an inch of
Ukrainian land in fact they wanted to go
and get back Crimea and other parts of
the country that have been taken by
Vladimir Putin
um you know what is your message now to
Vladimir Putin if he's watching this
what is your message to him and his
military about that question
um would Ukraine ever do you think seed
an inch of land
my message to the Russian military would
be something that our president Mr
zelensky has had so many times
surrender or be destroyed this is the
only two possible outcomes for these war
criminals they are already degraded by
the Ukrainian army they are demoralized
we are seeing they are deserting the
battlefield you know by now we have
killed more than 210
000 Russian soldiers on the battlefield
and the News spreads and this is why
we're seeing the beginning of this Civil
War in Russia you know all these
movements the partisans in the belgaum
region uh so this is my message to the
soldiers through uh the terrorist number
one the leader of Kremlin I would say
begin rehearsing your speech when you
will be standing in the docks of an
international Warcraft tribunal because
this war criminal has already had one
indictment issued against him and after
today I think somewhere now as we speak
another one is being written uh so his
the leader of Kremlin and his Clique
they will all stand trial now as for
ukrainians you know we will continue to
fight because we understand at the level
of our DNA that this is a war of fast
survival this is a historical chance for
us to once and for all resolve this
issue Russia this war has begun not on
February in February 2022 it began not
even in 2014 when Russia illegally
enacts Crimea and started the war in the
east of Ukraine this is something that
Russia and this genocidal maniac and
monster was trying to achieve for
centuries destroy the Ukrainian identity
destroy the Ukrainian culture and
destroy us as a nation this will never
happen I'll give you my word for this
General briefly if you don't mind but
what what is the importance of this war
now to the rest of the world are people
like China Iran other countries watching
to see what happens here would a victory
for Putin unleash just yet more hell
around the globe from people like those
countries would feel emboldened perhaps
attack Taiwan and so on how significant
is this now
I think you're exactly right if they see
aggression go wrong with it they have no
reason to be deterred the reason to stop
I think the first issue would be that as
you say China would do an unprecedented
attack into Taiwan uh you'd see other
dictators around the world uh revive
their own personal aspirations for lands
outside of their country so as the
defense advisor said we must show
approvalent that the will not be
rewarded for this illegal aggression
General thank you very much indeed and
Yuri Sac thank you both very much David
Jordan I appreciate it
well I'm joining the studio by the
political journalist Ava Santina and the
German well the journalist coincidence
he's more than a journalist he's a
legend he's a Fleet Street icon
desperate old hack a political
journalist a a thespian writer I mean
you're everything aren't you a bit of
everything an all-rounder both of them
of Journalism too much
uh Courtney what are you I mean I'm
always very inspired when I hear the
ukrainians talk they've got something
about them that is just inspiring that
resolve the iron determination people
weren't expecting this to be going on no
they thought Russia would roll them over
no no indeed on the face of it there's
dams destruction there's very bad news
for the ukrainians but psychologically I
think it tells us something about the
Russians we used to talk about a
scorched Earth policy this is a drenched
Earth policy if you like but the
scorched Earth policy that that business
of destroying a country as you are
retreating and it shows that the
Russians mentally are in Retreat and it
shows that they're giving up on the idea
of taking more of Ukraine and Henry
Kissinger made a good point uh last week
he said that the Russians have basically
already lost because or Putin has
already lost because the West no longer
fears that it it that Russia will attack
a European another European country and
I think that's a pretty shrewd point the
Russians have lost strategic purchase as
a deterrent uh
I mean look putting politics aside both
Boris Johnson and Richie soon and of
course very briefly Liz trust we have
been as as a country emphatically behind
the ukrainians impressively so I think
yeah I mean but importantly that's
because Europe has so much more to lose
than Putin has to gain realistically I
mean you know if Russia were to take
that land what does that say for you
know who we are as the Western World and
look you know this Dam I actually do
think it's a lot more important that
perhaps we've laid a claim to I mean you
think of the human effect of what's
happening right there all of those
emergency services are going to be drawn
to the area that's a dam the water of
which you know calls the energy uh
energy supply unit nearby think about
all the people who've lost their homes
all these Villages being absolutely
the water also was used for irrigation
of the uh of the field so it's more bad
news for food prices maybe I want to say
what is something uh much more trivial
uh but interesting nonetheless Michael
Sheen one of the great Welsh actors
um said he's he's found it very hard to
accept when Welsh characters are not
played by Welsh actors and has
criticized what he calls Posh Stars cast
in working class roles now we did a bit
of research into Mr Sheen I think we've
got some of his roles here which we can
show you um
let's have a look it's a VT
as far as I'm concerned the first thing
you can do for me is to chock all your
medals and all your caps and all your
pots and all your patterns into the
biggest flipping Dustbin you can find
Bella is alive oh
isn't that wonderful
I love a happy ending
you
angels
well to recap we found 10 he played
Brian Clover Yorkshire and Tony Berry
Scott David Frost Englishman HD Wells
Englishman William H Masters American
Sigmund Freud check Nero and Italian
Hamlet Dane Mozart and Austrian Jesus
Christ of Palestinian his Hamlet wasn't
very good but I rest my case he's good
actor though he's a good actor but I
think there's another point he's a great
actor that can play all the
I don't scream when I hear a Welshman
playing Tony Blair in a Blair accent
what's he on about I think Michael is
being what the Welsh would call a pill
log
and I mean it's it's a ludicrous um
proposition really because actually it's
very self-defeating there are very few
uh Welsh Parts in in World drama so he
may be doing himself out of a job
because if only Welsh can play Welsh
that means you know the way what about
this point about Posh Stars cast in
working class wrong is there a point to
that I mean this is a reverberating
debate isn't it we should only disable
actors play disabled roles and so on and
so on what about the the Posh V Working
Class part the point is representation
so this this whole Welsh argument is
silly but the point being that if you
grow up in a small Village in Wales you
don't have access to getting into acting
you don't have the transport links you
don't have the money to go into it you
know perhaps it may be children who've
been born into London you know two words
yes two words for you and they were
words of a man I had a wonderful
40-minute private chat with a dinner
party the other night Michael Kane
you don't get them all working class
actor than Michael Kane 150 something
movies he told me he's made playing you
know often I don't know if I could name
one
[Laughter]
realistically do you know the problem is
with these actors though is that they
they go to private school they get into
active and they put all the ladder up
for everyone else they go no I've had it
and I'm Posh but you know you know what
I actually can't tolerate you sitting
here any longer for not knowing who
Michael Kane is or not even
understanding he's all great exactly but
I think we're through all this class
stuff I mean this is such shall we
aren't we so aren't we through stuff I
used to be a dustman would I be able to
play a dustman on screen no you were a
dustman I was a dustman once that's a
staggering bombshell but I would not be
able to play you gotta drop this
bombshell quenching less
sister what's Oxfordshire I literally a
bin man yeah in the days when there were
metal bins full of Ash
what was the most disgusting thing you
ever had to deal with I can't remember
anything disgusting I just smelt for
about two two weeks after I took on me
terrible have you got any weird little
little things in your back catalog I was
a delivery driver I used to drive a
white van that used to really impressive
I was a white van delivery driver for
years and you still don't know Michael
Kane's movies yeah Dirty Rotten
Scoundrels The Italian Job
Alfie I mean for goodness sake he's one
of the greatest actors ever it's quite a
right now you're you're going that's the
end you out of the studio you're being
censored uh
not so great uh lost on your loss on
your reputation well Kevin there's a
controversial website only fans so
there's another three million creators
who mostly make money by selling racy if
not downright pornographic pictures it's
a phenomenon but is it empowering is it
a feminist statement of some claim or is
it just sleazy or debate that makes
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
has become a digital phenomenon there's
190 million users and three million
so-called creators who mostly use the
space to upload x-rated photographs and
videos of themselves for their
subscribers and it's big business very
big business raking in five billion
dollars a year Well Ellie Brooke who
makes six to seven figures per month on
the site describes it as empowering but
after years of fighting back against the
objective use of women in newspapers
magazines and his cheerleaders and Sport
isn't it just well a bit of a backward
step well joining me now is only fans
Creator L Brooke I did ask and then got
it wrong didn't I I'm the host of The
Blair White Project Blair white over in
the state so welcome to both of you all
right l now tell me about yourself yeah
what were you before you did this
um I was a law student
um and now I'm a teacher a university
yeah a university in your Southampton so
did you graduate or no no I dropped out
to do any fans because I was making a
lot of money so I was like why am I
doing reading starting to be a lot a
lawyer yes and then you start doing only
fans while you're at University yes what
made you get into it because I saw how
much money other people were earning and
I was thinking hey I can do this too and
then it turns out I'm pretty good at
getting my clothes off and I was like
this is a career for me okay look I've
nothing against you I don't I'm not
taking a moral view here right you can
do it the hell your life is legal uh I'm
just disappointed that someone like you
is obviously got a great brain yeah
training to be a law student at
University
decides to pack it all in to just take
your clothes off for perfect strangers
on only fans why because I wouldn't have
made loads of money as a solicitor
anyway like I would have earned money
yes so I earned that in two weeks now
and I earned that throughout you how
much do you make I mean how much money
do you make I earn a lot how much do you
make maybe like double that well I won't
get into what I am but what do you earn
I I earn a lot of money well I don't
want to give a specific number but I'm
0.01 on only phone so I'm as top as it
gets what does that mean it means you
are the best of the best 0.01 best to
the best of one any fans creditors in
monetary terms why are you so good
because I'm really good looking
right an original we're certainly not
shy are you no I know I'm good at what I
do I'm not gonna harangue you for being
cocky because that would be ridiculous
coming from me but um all right well let
me go to to Blair here I mean Blair look
on the face of it isn't this really what
feminist empowerment's all about a woman
in control of her body doing what she
wants with it making a huge amount of
money isn't it entirely down to L what
she decides to do
it absolutely is up to Al to do whatever
she wants to do in her professional
career and I don't have any issue with
adults doing what they want entering sex
work however unfortunately I think the
way in which only fans is often
discussed in public makes it out to be
this quick Get Rich scheme it reeks of a
pyramid scheme and oftentimes young
girls find themselves following this
Fool's Gold Rush and not really
understanding the consequences of it so
here's some information that I feel like
young girls should arm themselves with
the average registered only fans Creator
makes only 180 dollars a month that's
the average so we're not discussing l in
that obviously but that is the average
making about 2500 a month puts you in
the top one percent which adds up to 15
an hour which is the same or less than
McDonald's pays so oftentimes these
young girls find themselves you know
entering sex work thinking that it's
going to be financially you know
beneficial for them and they end up
making less than a fast food worker but
they still take on the entire stigma of
being involved in sex work and
oftentimes you can't find employment
after afterwards so my only issue is
people doing these things without having
you know themselves armed with the
information and I think everyone should
know what them together yeah you make
some good points I mean what do your
family think of this I mean they must be
incredibly disappointed surely that you
backed in a potentially really
successful career as a lawyer to do this
yes my dad is dead and my mum is on my
payroll my family your mom's on your
payroll my mother's on my payroll what
do you want
um admin what does that mean it's just
behind the scenes work she doesn't do
anything rude or anything so she loves
you doing this well she doesn't praise
it at the pub like woohoo my daughter
does only fans but she's supportive she
knows that I'm over 18 I can do what the
hell I want and she knows that you know
her views can't like impact my life what
is she gonna do you're grounded because
you do only fans like what the hell is
2023 people do what the hell they want
no no don't get me wrong I totally
subscribe to that and we the show you
subscribe uh I just subscribed to you
but uh
um I haven't bestowed you that honor yet
no but the look I think this Show's
called uncensored you can do it you're
like I don't care but I'm just curious
about you being someone who embarked on
a a law career was obviously very bright
went to University packed it in just for
money to be effectively an online
stripper I mean that's what you do right
yeah way worse than an online stripper
but uh what do you mean
online strippers just you know naked I
do things that are way more grotesque
just pornography pornography anything
but it's all then what I want to do and
I absolutely love it and I'm really good
at it you know I could be a good lawyer
yes but also am I good at doing other
things on video on camera how would you
feel when you want to have kids yourself
well I mean that's I I don't really want
kids right now how old are you 25 right
so you will do some stage probably right
when you do you're going to be proud
that you have your little ones and they
look at you and go didn't you want to be
a lawyer mummy what happened yeah you go
yeah but look at all my stuff they can
cry on a Ferrari
all right
you see there will be I know there will
be people watching this especially
younger people cheering you on yeah girl
you go well and then other people going
what what are you what are you sounding
like you sound awful good task it's like
why why go down this road you've
obviously you could be doing something
so much better for the world than this
couldn't you no I've been so
um like sexually open since I was at
school and if you met anyone in my year
group they would be like you are
absolutely made to do this and I think
if you put your mind to something then
you can absolutely achieve it like look
at me with a little bit of good looks
and hard work you can become a
millionaire look you know play Devil's
Advocate Blair I mean look you know we I
saw you rolling your eyes but the bottom
line is she's making millions doing what
she enjoys doing
um
very popular I mean who are we to be too
prudish about it frankly
it's nothing to do with Albert I think
it's important to state that it's not
just about having good looks and a
little bit of work ethic because
oftentimes like I just said you could be
incredibly good looking at only fans and
only bring in 180 a month and still take
on the entire stigma doing sex work so
while it's important to you know say
that everyone can do what they want we
do have to acknowledge that L is the
exception not the rule and oftentimes
these young girls sometimes on their
18th birthday are being misled into
joining the site that completely
demolishes any prospects of future
employment for them and often
statistically any chances of having
relationships a lot of only fans girls
are actually regretting being on the
website coming forward and saying they
can't get a job now and they can't get a
date and they never even made the money
to justify doing so happy for L but
that's the exception okay yeah let me
ask you on that point I mean do you have
a a man or no you want a man no I'm
single at the moment but can I just
point out that people fail at jobs all
the time like just because you didn't
make it as an actor do you regret being
an actor like so many companies go
Brusque bus and like
sorry
I said but if you fail at McDonald's you
didn't flip a burger correctly for a
customer if you fail at only fans
there's videos and pictures of you
having sex or being naked on the
internet forever you make that choice
it's not like loads of people fail no I
know
information but you should be armed with
the information is what I'm saying you
need to say that honestly what does it
say about Society where a bright young
woman like you yeah right decides to
abandon a career in a fantastic career
as a lawyer to do this just because it's
making you money online what does it say
about the way Society is gone
that I'm successful no matter what I do
I'd be successful as anything it'd just
be pretty proud of you are you proud of
it though yeah of course I am of course
I am more than you would be the only
fans I box I have a big social presence
I have everything and only fans was my
gateway to become this influencer that I
am now I want to be an influencer really
who wants any any maybe not any fans but
anyway
pretty shallow people I've got to be
honest because they think they're a
great influencing on people but most of
them aren't they're a bad influence I
feel like now you've been to platforms
you're kind of an influencer really yeah
I don't know just you could have any
views online and post them on your own
influence that's true that that has me
as you that's true but I see myself as a
journalist it was a career I always
wanted to do you would have been a
lawyer if you hadn't taken this path I
reckon I'll interview again in 15 years
yeah and you'll say you know what Pez
you were right I'll pick you up in my
Bugatti okay well it'll be one or the
other thank you for coming in I'll
appreciate it and thank you Blair
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much I'm sensored next the world needs
to toughen up a bit doesn't it legendary
Wellness Guru to the Stars Wim Hof says
he can freeze the fear out of you and
put ice in your veins he joins me live
next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
over the last few years the worldwide
Wellness industry has exploded in
popularity and profitability that
there's estimated to be worth around 4.2
trillion dollars a year but if you
thought it was all about Gwyneth
Paltrow's intimately scented candles or
something kale smoothies while adopting
the downward dog and my next guest is
here to put you right Wim Hof is the
Dutch lifestyle Guru whose radical
extreme cold therapy method has made him
a Sunday Times bestselling author and
motivational speaker to Millions more
importantly in a world of snowflakes is
promised to freeze a fear by putting ice
in our veins it surely needed more than
ever I'm thrilled to say the Iceman
joins me now well welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored Wim thank you very
much indeed for joining me
thank you pierce for having me on your
conversation thank you well I'm kind of
fascinated by you because I I was
it was a quotes you came out with you
said we are as a society have become
snowflakes doctors prescribe too many
pills treating symptoms like anxiety and
depression but not the cause connection
with nature is profound cold water is
the remedy exercise connection with the
natural world is Paramount ridicted to
phones iPads laptops and machines
despite dopamine but it's futile and
makes us miserable Tech has made us weak
and I when I read that I was like
Hallelujah that somebody with a big
following with influence is saying what
is clearly ever more obvious
yes and it is so we have abstracted
through our technology and I welcome
technology but I welcome biological
technology of the human body even more
how to maintain and activate and create
and guarantee our own happiness strength
and health we lost that connection with
us so I came up with a way to tap into
the deeper physiology and endorse it by
scientific uh scrutiny by comparative
studies so there is no speculation about
it we got they injected us a group I
trained into this method in four days
and they were able to withstand a
endotoxin that is a E coli bacteria
injected into the veins and they were
able to bring down these symptoms
whereas 16 000 others could not and now
suddenly 12 people trained by me in four
days were able to bring down to suppress
the inflammation caused by a bacteria
and that is revolutionary it shows that
we lost the connection with our deeper
systems inside which is the immune
system the endocrine system the
cardiovascular system and we have no
control over that anymore and now I have
shown by going into nature then going
through science uh showing it in groups
that we are able to retrieve a deep
connection with our systems and at
command are able to exercise power over
that What Makes Us sick depressed and
lack of energy you know it's very it's
fascinating and I've got I've got to say
quite an increasing number of friends
who go and do this Wild Water Swimming
you know freezing cold and jump in and
they swear by it they they think it's
been really good for their mental health
it's been good for their physical health
um so I you know I definitely sense a
lot of people are trying forms of this
um what's interesting to me uh is how
you really got into this and the sort of
pivotal moment in your life came through
utter tragedy where your first wife uh
took her own life she was suffering from
schizophrenia uh took her own life and
you were left with your four children
and it inspired you to really go down
this road of ice cold as a form of
therapy for you how important do you
think that that was for you in getting
over that appalling tragedy
back then there was no other remedy in
my life I had little money four kids
alone and a wife she was the love of my
life so you are heartbroken emotionally
you are in agony it goes around around I
had no control over that but I remember
to go into the cold the cold it makes
you stop thinking it just breaks the
loop of the emotional Agony and that
directly gave me a relief just a little
time without being into that Loop was
able to bring about this healing from
the inside so of course I went on doing
this all the time since 95 and I did it
very consciously because I had to bring
up four kids alone with little money the
cold I tell you pierced the cold and the
breathing techniques they gave me all
the bloody energy to make a warm nest
for my children amazing and make me able
to process all the emotional Agony and
now I say what back then the oldest
psychiatrists did not know I am working
right now with the best psychiatrists of
the world to show that we we are so much
more capable to tap into our emotional
Agony and learn to process trauma we got
him we got him and I want to bring it
and therefore I thank you for me bring
it through your show to so many people
well I think honestly I think it's a
really I think it's really interesting
and never mind nothing else you've
broken 21 Guinness world records
including I'm going to read some of
these out running a half marathon above
the Arctic Circle barefoot in shorts
swimming underneath ice for 66 meters
hanging on one finger at an altitude of
2 000 meters climbing the highest
mountains in the world while wearing
again only shorts and standing on a
container while covered with ice cubes
for more than 112 minutes now apart from
the fact that you're clearly
well you're different to the rest of
this is how I would put it politely
which of those was the hardest
the hardest is where it was most
impressive every time I do a world
record I am ready
to take on fully hundred percent of my
body and mind I know how to do that I
learned how to climb without gear uh
steep walls I learned to trust myself
breath hold and swim 60 70 80 meters
under the eyes Just Breath hold and in
short things like that you cannot do if
you don't do do it with a full
confidence and trust and control within
so my twin brother my identical twin
brother is absolutely not able to do
what I do do his body is the same as me
genetically but I am very able to do it
so I saw if you train your body you are
able to do what in science
physiologically okay is thought
impossible well I've got to jump in
because I wanted to end by actually
enacting your work we found a member of
the talk TV team Lauren who is a massive
fan of yours and we thought of you such
a big fan we'd strip him down and Chuck
him in to an ice bucket at the top of
our building so Lauren has a tribute to
Wim Hof and thank you win very much and
D for coming on Facebook and uncensored
we have a very uncensored member of
talktv's Team about to ice himself
hopefully not to death take it away
Lauren
cheers Bears ready
good luck Lauren
breathe deep
in control
you
lovely wait how long do we leave him
there
two minutes until
mascularly he is totally at ease all
right leave him the job is done all
right leave him five minutes until total
paralysis sets in he's he's not had the
best of years here so it's the only
punishment he'll understand I think it
will not happen uh Lauren during this
sport there and you've had a very good
year uh well thank you very much indeed
for joining me I appreciate it
love it thank you good luck stay cold
and says the next a stunning sporting
development PGA golf agrees to merge
with his arch nemesis the rivals Saudi
Arabia funded live golf tour has it sold
out golf to the sports washers we'll
debate that next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk Prince Harry
blasts the media in court but was it
evidence High On Emotion but short on
facts MPS grow an ITV big wig over the
company's handling of the Phillips
Schofield Scandal and Final Call for
EasyJet as the airline comes up with 25
options for staff pronouns on their name
badges that's all at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh consensus a
PGA Tour on live golf just entered a
shocking unprecedented and very
unexpected merger after a year of bitter
dispute legal action disruption to the
men's game and questions surrounding
human rights the two sides today
suddenly announced they're going to be
best friends pga's commissioner has
described Union's historic day for the
game having previously Savage lived goal
for selling out to what he saw as a
brutal Saudi regime the tour has long
had a monopoly on Elite Golf and their
besting criticism of the Breakaway Saudi
tour so how's it sold out and why I'm
joined now by the American Sports
journalist clay Travis and the human
rights law and former leads United
management director David Hagel welcome
to both of you now David
um I want to play you a clip this is Jay
money and he's a commissioner of the PGA
this is n't said when he was asked
directly about uh Fury from the
relatives victims of 9 11 about the live
tour being funded by Saudi Arabia this
is what the PGA commissioner said at the
time
9 11 families United sent a letter to
the representatives of Phil Dustin
Bryson Reed and others
quote expressing their outrage towards
the golfers
for participating in the new league I
think you'd have to be living under a
rock to not know that there are
significant implications
and I would ask you know any player that
has left or any player that would ever
consider leaving
have you ever had to apologize for being
a member of the PGA tour
I mean it's pretty breathtaking isn't it
uh David we're now in a place where the
same day morning is saying this is now
the greatest thing since Live's bread
having taken a lot of bread from the
Saudis he was so Furious about
absolutely and and good good evening and
I think it's going to be very difficult
for him to come back from that and you
know I speak from personal experiences
peers as you may may remember I mean 10
years ago I brought effectively
um Islamic money from State estate
controlled Islamic Investment Bank into
Leeds United
um and as the lead United fans know full
well that did not end well it ended with
likes of trying to ban uh uh alcohol
from football clubs and all sorts of
very terrible things and and poor
results on the field so I speak from
from experience in that sense and
obviously now working human rights
defending the very people that people
like Saudi in the UAE
um torture and and abuse so I think it's
it's a shocking situation and and it's
it's not just about one Club it's not
just about football it's not just about
golf but where does this end is this yet
another stop on on a very dangerous road
to to control a sport by the by the
wrong people where quality all right
well that's look it's a question a lot
of people are asked talking clay I've
got to say my reaction to all this I'm a
big golf fan I know a lot of the golfers
no filmmakers in quite well no Rory
McIlroy well uh seen both sides of this
debate raging away and I read a piece of
the New York Post uh when it was all
bubbling away last year saying I think
there's a stinking hypocrisy at the
heart of the PGA position they go and
have tournaments in China for example
without Banning an eyelid many of the
sponsors do huge business in the Middle
East including Saudi so the whole debate
to me was always about money and power
and control it was never really about
morality
oh 100 and that's why I never had any
issue with the decision that Phil
Mickelson made or the decision uh that
uh that that you would see happening
with Brooks kepca look those guys were
trying to make the most money and the
people who I think have the most right
to be angry right now Tiger Woods
reportedly Pierce turned down 750
million dollars Rory McIlroy turned down
hundreds of millions of dollars Justin
Thomas and now the PGA itself is going
to take the money that they decried as
blood money and tried to connect to 911.
if I'm Jay Monahan I don't know how I
face all those guys and look at them and
say why is it okay for us to take the
money but you individual golfers who did
it who have far less resources than we
do You Were Somehow a pariah and I'll
also mention this do you know Anthony
blinken Secretary of State Pierce is on
his way to Saudi Arabia right now right
if you're in America or anywhere around
the world wouldn't you want to criticize
a guy like Joe Biden for are given a
fist pound to Mohammed bin Salman and
begging for him to decrease the price of
oil the government's going over there
and begging for Saudi Arabia to have an
impact why in the world do we care more
about what Phil Mickelson does in terms
of how he makes money I think this has
always been right I gotta say I found
the way Phil Mickelson was vilified
absolutely pathetic actually but I also
have to say that I also thought someone
like Rory McIlroy did it from a position
of being principled and being honorable
he wanted to support his tour
um and he will be he will be feeling
yeah but he'll be seething tonight I'm
sure oh I mean I he must be in fact they
all found out at the same time uh
literally like a couple of hours ago
bang so how this guy this is the thing
David egg I mean I don't know how Jay
morning stays as commissioner how can
you evoke
the memory of the victims of 9 11 as a
reason not to do business with Saudi
Arabia and then literally jump into bed
with the Saudis I mean how can you do
that
you can't and you know his position is
untenable going forward there's no way
that he can now publicly represent a a
an organization that owned him that he's
vilified quite rightly and so that I I
imagine his tenure will not be long
lived going going forward because he's a
complete hypocrisy
um and you know the end of the day it's
the the question that we all need to to
ask ourselves is do we want politics and
religion controlling World sport I think
okay let me jump in on that I I have a
problem with that and I'll come back to
you clay on this I I I love sport a good
friend of mine is Cristiano Ronaldo who
went to Saudi Arabia is playing a
football out there he loves it a lot of
big football stars are going out there
possibly his great rival Messi we know
Ben zamares and others there's a really
big league being built they love their
sport in Saudi Arabia when I was in
Qatar for the World Cup the number of
Saudis over there loving it why
shouldn't they be allowed to invest and
enjoy sport like we do and if we're all
gonna get very moral about this you know
the UK the us the what I would consider
the illegal invasion of Iraq and so on
and we are we so pure are we so morally
perfect the only we can host sporting
tournaments or invest in sport
look all of us on some level work for
billionaires so the idea that you're
going to somehow arbitrate whether
you're allowed to work for this
billionaire or not I think is
fundamentally wrong and yes I I think
look these guys have relatively short
shelf lights to make the most possible
money and again that's why I come back
to Tiger Woods and Rory McIlroy yeah
they're the guy free right now because
PGA and live are merged they turned down
hundreds of millions of dollars money
that they'll never make back I think
clay uh We've run out of time but I
think the Fallout from this is going to
be big watch this space play great
assault you David thank you very much
appreciate it guys whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]